[Musique]
ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui des
fondateurs d'un sursaut d'une droite
moderne ouverte et résolument tourné
vers l'avenir
quel autre parti politique est capable
aujourd'hui de rassembler plus de 1000
jeunes pendant deux jours pour parler
politique pour travailler et parler de
l'avenir de notre pays je viens de
montpellier dans l'hérault
donc nous avons fait beaucoup de train
ce matin pour venir je viens de nîmes je
viens de seine maritime du havre
nous on vient de sauter dans les
hauts-de-seine du coup français de
l'étranger mais en allemagne je viens de
nice avec une cinquantaine de jeunes du
département des alpes-maritimes on a
fait un long trajet on a fait du teaser
de train plus d'un millier de jeunes
venus de toute la france sont réunis ici
pour deux journées deux journées durant
lesquelles ils débattent de la question
de la conciliation de la croissance et
de l'écologie des souverainetés et de
l'europe de la république la question
des réussites de l'ascenseur social
bref tous ces sujets qui sont essentiels
et qui sont l'adn de notre famille
politique il n'ya pas de politique sans
conviction sans valeur sans idée merci à
tous de votre présence si ça fait
plaisir parce qu'on se dit tenu les
jeunes valeurs 3000 jeunes
c'est écrit
et ça c'est
grâce à vous grâce à notre mobilisation
[Musique]
d'avoir un parti qui ose dire bah voilà
on fait un événement juste pour vous les
jeunes venaient et en plus de ça on vous
donne la parole on va pas juste vous
faire asseoir sur un siège et écouter
écouter les grands noms de la politique
vous allez pouvoir vous exprimer en plus
de ça sans langue de bois et ça c'est
super faire le choix de la jeunesse pour
ouvrir cette rentrée politique
c'est un choix extrêmement fort c'est un
signal d'optimisme et de foi en l'avenir
les républicains ici nous permet de nous
exprimer et de donner notre avis est de
construire ma un projet ensemble en tant
que citoyen votre engagement politique
c'est celui là c'est de vous interroger
ça fait partie des valeurs des
républicains ça fait partie de notre
manière de faire de la politique et donc
continuons aujourd'hui ce formidable
débat d'idées on nous a laissés vraiment
le temps de parler sur les points qui
nous tenait à coeur
et chacun a pu exprimer ses opinions et
ça a été vraiment très enrichissant
l'immigration
parce que
l'urgence climatique ne doit pas se
faire au détriment de l'urgence
économique
ça a été un échange fabuleux parce que
il n'y a pas eu de tabou on a posé des
questions y compris poil à gratter
donc on a quelques idées qui sortent un
petit peu des sentiers battus ces débats
ces oppositions et même ses
complémentarités vont pouvoir permettre
l'émergence de propositions beaucoup
plus concrète je crois que les jeunes
ont fait preuve vraiment de beaucoup
d'intérêt d'abord sur la question
européenne
j'espère que parmi tous ces jeunes qui
sont présents il ya des futurs ministres
des futures mères des futurs présidents
la république c'est ça dont on a besoin
[Applaudissements]
restez comme vous êtes justement avec
votre veste vous habib république un
profond fier regardez tout le monde
droit devant avec beaucoup de bonheur
beaucoup de compassion beaucoup
d'empathie mais aussi beaucoup de
détermination qui se font sur ces jeunes
c'est un parti vivant c'est un parti
[Musique]
c'est la première fois que je participe
à un événement comme celui-ci
franchement je suis rapide c'était super
motivant c'était super encourageant les
très beaux discours des belles tables
rondes et des ateliers on a pu discuter
poser des questions débattre donc voilà
que du positif
si nous abordons l'été prochain avec la
formidable victoire qui était la nôtre
municipale à laquelle nous allons
ajouter des sénatoriales réussi et puis
auxquels nous ajouterons j'en suis
convaincu des départementales et des
régionales victorieuse et puis également
un mouvement de jeunesse structuré et
enfin un projet politique qui réponde
aux attentes de nos concitoyens et qui
traduisent de réelles perspectives une
vraie vision pour notre pays
alors alors nous aurons toutes les armes
pour nous rassembler derrière celui ou
celle qui nous fera gagner en 2022
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]